these things more to say 10 minutes okay
okay I noticed so in one in one in one
person's exercise that be was that there
was a little bit of of confusion about
punctuation with with respect to
mathematics formulas and the reason is
is easy to understand because there are
two rules that just the opposite of each
other if you're in in the middle of a
paragraph the punctuation belongs after
the dollar sign so you would say X comma
outside the dollar sign why Dawson comma
and Z and then I might even say this is
psychologically bad break here but you
see the punctuation is an interior Lisa
call go outside the dock if I put them
inside then tech wouldn't know that they
were Commons and it wouldn't have
treated them quite nice and quite right
for the text in fact if I had left out
these two dollar signs entirely then x
and y would have come rather close
together and the final paragraph would
look lean on XY and z and this base
after the comma would be just a thin
space instead of your ordinary inter
word space so so you want to get the
right spacing the general rule almost
always keep the punctuation outside the
things but in displays it's just the
opposite when you have double dollar
sign and there's and it ends with a
period you know you have some formula
equals Z or something like that and then
ends with a period then you definitely
want the period inside the double dots
on because you put of that if you put it
outside you see what's going to happen
first of all this if the formula will be
centered you're going to get a period on
the next line after the display okay so
rules for display tend to be the
opposite similarly for blank for
breaking up a formula in the middle of a
paragraph usually you'll say X plus y
plus at the end of a line in in the
middle of a text and then come Z plus W
on the next
I would be acceptable if you had to make
a break there but in a displayed formula
typically it would align would end X
plus y the next line would say plus C
plus W and I noticed we looking at one
polish journal where they put the plus
sign in both places in the display to
please everybody I guess in but in a
display then there tend to be a
different rules from breaking things and
function and punctuating things and then
in an in-text and punctuation it's easy
to remember I think that that it since
this this isn't part of the formula in a
text and keep it outside the dollar
signs but on the other hand for a
display it's part of the thing being
displayed so you keep it inside the
display next somebody said what about L
pile see pile in our pile Emanuel
mention sees as sort of an afterthought
is kind of a useful construction in
several places in mathematics L pile of
X can we have this on the screen click x
character and why carriage return Y Z
carriage return close bracket this if i
type this this means the left to
justified pile so the letters XY and z
are going to occur above each other
maybe you can't see that too well
because they all look about the same
with when i write them by hand suppose I
had y plus T then everybody they will be
they would do it come out this this L
pile builds a box that contains three
the all the formulas as many as you give
put a bow on top each other at the left
typical use of that would be if you if
you're giving a formula like absolute x
equals x if and then minus x if
something like that and then you could
make these two things above each other
by using an L pile for example you'd
have to you'd have to get the if in here
you'd have to go to H box to get out of
a math mode but but that's that's
examples of L pile or else sometimes you
have to have a list of numbers point 1
point 0 1 point 0 0 1 you'd like to have
those above each other left
Center similarly there's see pile and
our pile center pile and right right to
swipe out for lining them up at this you
know Center more right justified don't
forget the carriage return at the after
the last one or something strange might
happen it might if you're lucky it would
just say missing carriage return but
sometimes it's complicated in here then
something's cut it tries to say this
encourage each other but if you if you
also leave off a bracket or something
else anyway this is good don't forget
that carriage return there you're going
to get some aromatic and if you don't so
so these that builds the boxes and in
the final box is actually centered
vertically with respect to everything
else so if you give several L piles in
the same same line they'll all appear
centered with respect to each other
adjusted like a 33 line one and a four
line one of the four line one will will
be half a line up higher than the three
line one these only work in math well
that's in math mode young it's something
like an equation of line but without
without you know it's just much simpler
than an equation online now oh yeah this
is a very important one that most people
yeah i think that the basic format
covers almost everything that I mean it
covers most of the things that you need
for most papers except there's one thing
that I that I that I should have put in
basic format probably and and I probably
will eventually is is for hat when you
when someone is no wants to give a bunch
of lines that's say case 1 case 2 in
case 3 or something like that you want
to list the cases now I don't have a
exam thrill me it probably could find
one in in in in Thomas's book
just by just by eyeballing a few pages
until I get it well so far I don't see
one so i'll just have to oh yeah here's
one okay here's an example of a kind of
a thing that people that that that that
would occur here is a Roman numeral 1 2
& 3 & and furthermore if this had if
this Roman numeral one would have
continued on to several other lines it
would have been nice to have the
continuation lines all starting all
starting at the same at the same place
okay so that's a rather common thing and
and I should show you how to do it now
the macro that's there's a macro in
Appendix II called text indent which
which does this text indent and what I
would I would typically I would write in
my own book then if I were doing if I
were doing and I would say text indent
and then I would say one and then i
would say then i would give the next
that's the first part of the text /
whatever is whatever thomas said you
know and then and then I continue to the
end of a paragraph and then after the
end of a paragraph start another text
indent and this means the indentation
but the text takes the place of it okay
and then end and the rest of the
paragraph we'll start out in the
same at the same amount amount over with
the next case was completed so or not so
so I I had text indent of something and
that would that would cause everything
else we moved up another kind of a thing
that we that often goes in the text
indent is a of course a number in Roman
numeral or else a big heavy dot which is
called a bullet so you can say dollar
sign is its a math symbol dollar sign
bullet caused a sign that gives you a
bulleted list of alternatives you know
and say there are five way five reasons
why minus the best and and you say dot
this is it okay so so you get this
indentation now now hanging indentation
is is is that is something I should
I meant to say earlier today hanging
suppose I say hang indent 20 points this
would mean that every line after the
first is going to well I suppose I say
after after three this would mean that
the first three lines of the paragraph
gets set to set as normal but but the
fourth and subsequent lines get moved 20
points over and the line is is 20 points
short are narrower similarly I could say
hang it in 20 points for three and this
would mean at the first three lines the
first three lines I said over there and
then and then it reserves when I was
doing that fancy s the other day I would
Hank I had a hang ten on the second line
but it it disappeared at the end now in
order to handle the text indent hanging
down is a basic feature I mean is a the
built-in feature of tech text indent is
not as a control sequence that's defined
and added to the format but it uses
hanging indentation for the for the
subsequent line question if if so the
actual coding for text indent is it well
like this is a little bit beyond the
scope of our course but I would define
text indent and taking one parameter in
the following way I would say let's
suppose of my I i I've already decided
however exactly how much indentation is
going to be used let's suppose it's 20
points so then i'm going to say age box
to 20 points and this makes a box 20
points wide and then it says h fill
number one this box is now 20 points why
effect instead of H fill excuse me I'm
going to use HSS so that it can include
it might even stick into the margin if
you give it a long piece of text but
this will be 20 point slide and in this
HSS means horizontal stretching or
shrinking as needed and and and then in
comes the thing that you asked to be
inserted into the text indent and then
also i would say then i would say no
intent I'm sorry before I do that I have
no intent because I have to get this out
in the left margin so I say no and then
and then I then I give this and then I
say hang indent 20 points and contend
that's the end of the type of definition
of text indent hanging down by 20 points
now this means that second line and
subsequent lines will be indented by 20
points the first line was not indent at
all but I put a box in there that was 20
points wide and in fact I usually I
usually also put a space here leave a
space there also that otherwise things
will butt up against each other look
horrible so I should have left a space
right there also after the after the
parameter number one okay so that's that
that's a common thing that people
usually need and it's 10 when you're
putting several things in series like
that it's typical to give about three
points extra space above and below the
list of things makes it look a little
better now with annex ii of the tech
manual is a is a is an example of an
elaborate format that was used to
actually type set a complicated 700-page
book the book is now in the book story
it's the volume 2 of art of computer
programming it was done essentially
using all the control sequences defined
in Appendix II so for people who who
want to want to do you know you run into
a problem now and you say how am I going
to solve that how could I do it it
wasn't covered in the course it wasn't
covered in basic in the manual well one
thing you could do is go to the library
get a copy of this of this volume 2 that
was done with tech find a page where
that problem occurred on it probably the
good chance that that if that it
occurred somewhere in that book and then
go to the computer file for the tech
file that generated the book which is
online at sale and take a look at it at
at where it is these files for example
it's called v2 comedy EK v 2 30 30 to 34
tech v2 DK this is for section 3.4 of
the book v2 stands for volume 2 and it's
34 stands for section 3.4 and you'll be
able to find a find corresponding
solutions to all kinds of problems that
might arise if in case the case they
arrived okay I've covered everything on
the list except somebody had a few other
questions like how can you tilt the
spiral text like this I'm sorry that's
not allowed by most of our output
printers and the other questions that
this person asked are really more
appropriate for next week's with its
course gotta say one word in conclusion
people when they first are starting and
learning as you are this week there they
always say what about an interactive
version of text so that as I'm typing in
it would immediately appear on the
screen in front of my eyes exactly how
the formula is going to look and this is
something that that that everybody
desires very much in may and the
computer scientists who start to learn
tech also put in the back of their mind
that maybe that'll be their thesis so
they're going to do that next year
they're going to make that a project to
create such a system and then after two
weeks of using tech then they forget
about it because they've already
internalized all these the you know
enough of the language I did that they
don't even care what it may be they know
it's going to look like and they just
and they're interested in minimizing
keyboard strokes and I wouldn't bother
to look up if it were there and so and
so such interactive systems we started
out with great plans to do on and we
still probably will someday but we never
can find a student to do it because it
never seems to be the plea as important
after after you learn the system as as
in your first few minutes and i found
this universal i talked to people from
who have used many other devices for
computer input to printing and including
mathematics and me they all say the same
thing that after the learning phase is
over after you've done your first ten
pages or something of output then you
internalize it to the point where you
were you don't care that much about this
interactive system but it still be very
nice to have one to show the visitors
who come and the boss and so on that you
have this glorious thing that's sitting
over here in the car
not being used but they can play with it
and see the other nice use of an
interactive system like that is for the
very final tuning of a book where
somebody wants to change a paragraph in
the middle and would like to know that
the paragraph still going to come out
exactly the same number of lines or he's
going to rewrite it so that it does and
and then would like to see interactively
exactly what's going on there so that's
another use for such a system but it
isn't is it but it is and as but but I
believe you will find that as you get a
little more experience with it all of a
sudden you will know if you're typing it
what it's going to look like afterward
just have a few more tries before your
your cure your the keyboard and I open
the fact that you're doing it in direct
isn't going to in going to Bali okay I'm
sorry I run over time happy checking to
all of you
you